david tell me did you hear about the
richest new year's party
ever so it went down on a swiss
billionaire's mega yacht in the ritzy
island of saint balz
jeff bezos was there i'm not sure if
you've seen these memes going on he's
dressed up in a 70s disco outfit
basically people are clowning him
calling him basically the corny
billionaire version of jeff bezos i'm
sorry a pit bull
tons of celebrities were there leo drake
my girl crush dua lipa meek mill's there
performing little baby performed
basically 500 vips were there and if you
combine the net worth of these
500
vips that were there it would be more
than most countries
gdp that's the kind of party they're
doing on these mega yachts in saint
barts i might have said five vips 500
vips on this mega yacht 100 yes jeff
bezos was there they're clowning them
now are you a fan of jeff bezos yeah i
mean i'm i'm an amazon prime i
love amazon yeah yeah my life would not
be what it is today without amazon you
know people hate on jeff bezos he's too
rich he's too wealthy i use amazon he
hasn't underpaid me
[Laughter]
other people he has but anyway so people
are kind of clowning him but let me read
this story it's a page six story if you
want to pull this up yeah so the party
commenced aka it started at a dinner
party
at um there's a guy called richie akiva
i've actually met him a few times in my
party days he's uh he founded a partner
of butter the butter group they have
clubs like one oak in uh new york l.a
he's he's a he's a big wig so it started
off at his house at this party
and um then around 1am it moved to this
swiss billionaire's
150 million dollar
315 foot mega yacht i believe we have a
picture of the yacht somewhere and this
uh this swiss billionaire his name is
ernesto
bertarelli sounds more italian but you
know switzerland is next to italy um
while you're pulling up this boat side
note if you end up partying on new
year's on a swiss billionaire's yacht
you're doing all right for yourself
david how was your new year's by the way
dude i was invited to this party um
to this one the vip one
you were there yeah no i wasn't i just i
couldn't make it i was tied up i had
some stuff to do so i just spent it with
family oh but uh they they seemed to
have a good time
yeah you did end up going to that comedy
show where other friends of ours went
through it here in south florida i heard
some good stuff about that show our
friend nancy loved that [ __ ] i love that
show from what i hear so did gerard yep
um
so anyway there's you ever been to st
bart's by the way have you ever even
heard of st bart's
no okay
same parts i've actually been there
um
was i was in there i think 2016 it is a
french island in the caribbean so you
know
colonialization and all that kind of
good stuff that was going on france
basically went in there and took over
that island and it is a very found seed
it was so fancy that i ended up speaking
with a french accent the entire times
that i was there i don't i assumed a new
identity i actually not even kidding
right now went by the alias of
patrice
patrice exactly
um but uh luckily i was uh with some um
you know i would consider myself well
off i wouldn't say that i'm super rich
but i was with some super rich friends
yeah that took care of everything
um we did an episode about how basically
how to travel the world for free oh
that's right yeah i remember that uh
yeah yeah you know
help you know yeah yeah provide value
don't be a cheapskate throw in where you
can throw in so anyways i did that at
this uh trip to st bart's i was with my
my ex at the time we took a trip there
basically what it is is you have to fly
to i think saint martin's in a plane and
then from saint martin's you take a
puddle jumper literally like a
six person a puzzle chip a puddle jumper
um to fly to saint bards um like
it's such a small plane that it's a
pilot
one of our friends was sitting shotgun
in the plane and then five or six of us
were in the back that's how like small
the plane is right there and it's um
nerve-wracking as hell oh sorry your
trip to this i'm sorry that you had to
go to saint bards
i was so scared yeah but uh
i took an uncomfortable trip to orlando
this weekend
yeah orlando yeah disney world but uh
very nice place very expensive and um
i remember coming back into the country
and um
i'm pretty because it's a french island
i'm pretty sure i had euros yeah and i
remember exchanging what was the
equivalent of like
12 of euros
and all my rich friends are like look at
this loser you know taking the time to
cash out 12 bucks i'm like 12 bucks 12
bucks 12 bucks right yeah and i remember
having a picture of like ten dollars and
like
you know eight quarters in my hand and
my friends are gathering around like
look at this save that money loser i'm
like
yeah save that money but oh [ __ ] but
yeah
what would you do if you had twelve
dollars of euros would you just
yeah american money yeah save that money
save yeah what am i gonna store anyway
so that's my start same part so
basically let's get back to this party
they're on the yacht they're partying
meek mill's performing little baby doing
his little thing he's uh you know um
performing drake's there dua lipa i'm
like the biggest fan of dual leap yeah
total mega you should text you again
yeah she won't stop texting me so
awkward um
these basically these people were
partying until basically 10 a.m they
broke my cardinal scent oh no the only
reason i'm alive because i grew up in
south beach i lived in miami i've
partied
a lot
the only reason i'm alive right now
is number one i don't do like hard drugs
right i've been full disclosure on pbd
podcasts i'll smoke a joint from time to
time don't worry about that but i don't
mess with the powder the white stuff or
anything like that right and then here's
my rule sun's up
adam goes to bed
well i don't stay up yeah like there's
no benefit being up at 9am the next day
what's your like cut off whatever this
whatever like whenever the sun comes up
i'm just saying that's like
the rule holy hell like i'm sure i'm yes
i go to bed at midnight two o'clock
whatever but if it's 6 a.m the sun's
coming up i don't care what we're doing
i mean
i grew up in miami here like this is not
uncommon
so but that's my rule but anyways these
people partied till 10 am they broke my
cardinal sin but
you know of all this that's going on
saint bards
you know little baby drake people
partying
leonardo dicaprio's there the person
that's in the news the most
uh is this uh jeff bezos guy have you
seen the picture that is basically
circulating the interwebs right now the
tight shirt of him the tight shirt the
girlfriend on his side he's wearing like
heart-shaped glasses he's wearing a
disco
taco shirt uh everyone's talking about
his outfit now personally i don't give
two shits about his outfit he's at a is
that a disco party dressed up like he's
from the 70s more power to you bro if
you want to go on disco attire and you
want to be knockoff pitbull have at it
bro have your moment there it is all
good there it is yeah we got that he
looks like absolutely jacked yeah by the
way he is a little he's he's definitely
um looking better than ever that's um
this is the same guy that drove a honda
accord after he became a billionaire by
the way now he's you know mr cool guy
wearing his sunglasses jacked like you
said he's partying listen this is what
200 billion dollars and a nice fresh
divorce will do to a guy like that
that's so true okay this is a newly
divorced man right there and he's dating
her name is lauren sanchez she is the
ex-wife
of tony gonzalez that guy over there no
tony gonzalez is one of the greatest
football players greatest tight ends it
had
nfl history talking about a tight end
listen
that's so awkward dude
so these guys
just taking a picture together
i mean you know ah
i'm good it's an ex they broke up like
10 years ago they got a kid together
it's all good and is this the oh that's
what that's the kid that's the son
that's that's her son and that's that's
jeff bezos soon to be stepson that's
weird exactly well you know he's
probably your age you go be friends with
that guy you'll have a great time no he
doesn't look like a cool kid
that guy was raised rich he probably
sucks no he wasn't raised rich he was i
mean he wasn't jeff bezos he's
right he's my nfl player like yeah
wealthy but not
billionaire
um anyway people are so focused on this
outfit
and there's a there's a metaphor there
okay
um you know what i'm focusing on not on
the outfit i'm focusing because that's
the picture that he posted on instagram
i'm not posting on the actual picture he
posted i'm focusing on his caption his
message to his followers now he said
this
we had so much fun last night
celebrating with a crazy disco party
with the family but the new year is also
a great time to take stock and focus on
personal growth renewal rebirth and
paying careful attention to each moment
of your life
what's the analogy there most people new
years we talk about most people or most
people most people
party
they're hungover they're regretting
their decisions maybe from the night
before
um they go into the new year with
you know goals they go to the gym
they're going to eat healthy they're
going to do better and then two weeks
later they basically yeah succumb to the
pressures of normal life is money all we
talk is money
if you enjoyed that short clip from the
sauce cast click here to watch another
click here to watch the full episode or
just stay broke